Let's go to Fearis from Saudi Arabia.
You're calling from Saudi Arabia right now.
Yes, I am.
Nice to meet you, Dave.
Likewise.
And are you are you Saudi or are you of someone
working or living there?
No, I'm originally from Saudi.
I'm living here in the city just.
Yes, I am.
Is The David Pakman Show big in Saudi Arabia?
To be honest, I'm not 100 percent sure yet
because I've been watching some news about
what happened this covid-19 or the cases like
over 50 million.
My God, I'm very shocked.
Yes.
Yes, indeed.
Well, what can I do for you today?
Yeah, I have a question about Donald Trump,
I don't when I see the on the news, something
about operate to warp speed.
Yes.
In all or all of this election, all this any
it's all a complete mess.
And now he's making a self awful event.
I don't know how the.
Sorry, my Caguas.
Yeah, I can hear you.
Your cat seems very, very aggressive.
It is like this.
Just one second, please.
Sure, sure.
Listen, I may even have more questions for
you, but.
Yeah, yeah, go on.
So how do you feel about opening up women
driving?
Is that something you like?
Not really, but I'm just kind of surprised
that women finally can drive in the Arab,
but.
That's the good news, but so hold on a second.
You said you don't like it, but it is good
news.
No, no, no, no, I didn't say I don't like
it any I'm not I don't know the question,
to be honest.
No, no, I'm just asking, are you in favor
of women getting the ability to the legal
ability to drive in Saudi Arabia?
Yeah, I think they have the ability to drive.
No, I understand, of course, they have the
physical ability, just like anybody else,
but are you politically speaking, do you do
you like that?
Are you in favor of it?
In favor.
Do you support women driving in Saudi Arabia?
Yeah, I support it.
You do.
Sorry about that.
That's great.
I guess because my sister I have a sister.
And to be honest, because you need to drive
as well.
Right?
As a practical matter, you supported.
Yes, yeah, all right, fearis listen, this
is all very, very interesting.
I'm going to let you go because we do have
a lot of people waiting, but a very interesting
phone call.
And we had a cat and we had a number, a number
of different things going on there.